you we've sort of lost this ability in
America like like I remember when I was
a kid early 2000s I mean it was more
common to see racist sexist and
homophobic jokes let's just say as women
have entered the media and the workforce
you really see that going away because
and it's interesting that this is a dude
like actually that's saying that because
men are better able to take being made
fun of where women we just we just don't
really do it well and my plea to women
is if you want to be in a man's world if
you want to be on the internet if you
want to be in the media if you want to
do all this stuff then be in it be in it
don't cry and complain about being made
fun of later when you asked to be in a
guy's world that you didn't have to be
in and that's why you see this
phenomenon when women enter a space like
politics media and corporations you see
this phenomenon of people policing
speech